Speaker 1: All right. Let's start today, not
hyperbolically, but just in a way that aligns
with the facts. Letting you know that the polling
for the 2022 midterms in both the House and Senate
is looking a little bit worse for Democrats than
it was three weeks ago. There is a very clear,
although for now, not massive shift away from
Democrats towards Republicans in both the House
and Senate. And this just is another reminder
that we all have to vote and we have to take
nothing for granted. Let's start first with the
House of Representatives. Republicans have been
favored to win the House and they remain favored
to win the House. But the the rate the probability
of that event taking place has increased. And if
we look at the FiveThirtyEight forecast of the
House of Representatives, one of the things that
you see is that over time, the Democratic chances
of controlling the House surged from about
June through late September and then started
to decline. Now it is not a massive change, but
there is this inflection point in late September,
early October, wherein Republican odds of
controlling the House, taking control of the House
have increased. What do we do about it? Well, we
all have to vote. That doesn't change. But this
is starting to look like a trend. We then look
at the Senate. Democrats have been for a while
and remain favored to control the Senate after
the midterms to retain control. But again, if
you look at how those odds have changed, you see
an even more notable inflection point. Again, this
was right around, I don't know, mid-September. And
since mid-September, Democratic odds have declined
and Republican odds have increased. This doesn't
change that. The most likely outcome, the most
likely single outcome is that Democrats retain
control of the Senate and Democrats lose control
of the House. That's been the most statistically
likely outcome for a while now, but it's looking
a little bit less good in the in the Senate and
even worse than it was in the House. So what is
the takeaway? Later on in the show, we're going to
be looking at more debates from yesterday. We're
going to be looking at other polling and specific
races. The takeaway is simply every single state
has to be fought for and whether it's looking
like an easy Democratic win. So, for example,
there is a key race in Michigan. The governor
of Michigan, Gretchen Whitmer, the incumbent,
trying to beat off a challenge from Tudor Dixon.
And Whitmer is up by somewhere between eight and
11 points. It's looking pretty safe. But that does
that does that mean our Michigander viewers stay
home? I certainly hope not. Then you have very,
very tight races like, for example, in Arizona,
the Arizona gubernatorial where Carrie Lake, the
deranged big lie conspiracy theorist Republican,
is about half a point to one point ahead of Katie
Hobbs. That's a disaster. Do we stay home there?
No, actually, Arizona is one of the main places,
as I talked about yesterday, where we have to make
sure everybody's voting. And then there are
other races that are looking more in favor of
Republicans who an example would be tonight,
there's a debate in this race. Marco Rubio,
the incumbent Republican senator of Florida, he is
facing a challenge from Democratic Congresswoman
Val Demings. He's up like five or so. Do we give
that one up? Know whether the Democrat is up,
the Republican is up or it's a tight race? You're
allowed to vote. So take advantage and make sure
that you do vote. And we'll look in more detail
at some of these other races a little bit later.